- Good evening, everybody.
My name is Seenu Brahmarouthy
and together, along with
my colleague Leno Piperi
we're excited to talk to you about
monetizing agentic AI solutions.
Again, this is a session
designed specifically
for partners to provide you
some guidance on your journey
on agentic AI and how to
monetize and drive revenue.
So it's fascinating in terms
of gen AI, how we got here,
and the different waves of AI
and how we got to agentic AI.
If you think about it, there's
a couple of different waves
that we've gone through.
You know, a couple years
ago with Gen AI assistance
such as Claude and ChatGPT, you know,
we were able to automate
some of our day-to-day tasks.
And then as we advanced
into Gen AI agents,
which are powered by much
more powerful advanced models
with reasoning capabilities,
we are able to, you know,
automate some of the more complex tasks.
And now as we move into the agentic space
where everything is much
more fully autonomous,
we're seeing multi-agent type of systems.
The definition from AWS
in terms of what an AI agent is,
is an autonomous system
that can plan, reason,
and take action on behalf of a human.
So as you think about where
we are going into the future,
we believe there will be
billions of agents out there,
and this is a great
opportunity for partners
to take advantage of this wave
and show you some tips and tricks
in terms of how you can work with AWS.
So you may have heard about
all the different services
that we've launched,
but just a quick recap.
You know, all the way from applications
to development tools to
infrastructure that we offer.
We have applications
such as Kiro, Quick Suite
as well as AWS Marketplace,
which we'll double click
on in this session today.
We also have development
tools such as Bedrock
to find your models as
well as Bedrock AgentCore,
which is a building blocks
for building your agents specifically.
And then on the infrastructure
layer we have SageMaker,
which allows you to build
and deploy your own models,
and then finally compute with
cranium chips that we offer,
as well as the GPUs that we
have partnerships with Nvidia.
But just taking a step back
and looking at one
example of an ISV partner,
since this is a partner session
and a partner, you know,
guidance, you know,
Druva is one of our ISV partners
in the cloud data security space,
and they had a challenge with their team
in terms of being able to resolve
all of these security
issues for their customers.
And the team is getting really overwhelmed
with the complex number
of security workflows
that they had to resolve.
So they built a solution called DruAI,
which is embedded within
their SaaS application,
where it's multi-agent system
where their solution called DruAI
is built on Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
and they offer a multi-system
type of an architecture
where there's data agents,
inside agents, action agents
that give the ability
for customers to resolve,
and the results show
for the itself, right?
They're able to resolve
63% of the customer
security issues autonomously.
So just one example of a partner
that is adopted agentic AI
as part of their SaaS solution,
and they're seeing tremendous results.
Now, you know, feel free to take a QR code
to pull up the link here,
but I wanted to just share, you know,
as a partner going through
the journey of agentic AI
what are some of the product
and go-to market strategies
for you to consider in your journey
to bring agentic capabilities
within your own offerings?
So AWS published a white
paper a couple months ago
called "Rethinking SaaS
in the Agentic Era"
and really boils down to
four different strategies
that you can think about.
The first one, and both
of those strategies
are dependent based on product
and go to market, right?
With product, you're
thinking about new features,
either new features or
completely new products.
And from a go to market perspective,
it's either your existing customer base
or new customer base
that you're going after.
So let me go one by one
just to kind of share,
you know, at least from a high level.
So the first strategy is
around extending, right?
This is around new users
with existing customer base.
So here you're expanding the
scope of your existing products
with new features and
agentic type of features.
And in this approach, you
can possibly have an upsell
as a strategy and charge a little bit more
as one of your strategies
as you're extending and bringing
more agentic capabilities.
And then if you look
on the right hand side,
on the far right on top,
it's build, building new products
and targeting new
customers with new personas
and new markets.
There's definitely some risk involved here
because you're building something
a little bit forward thinking,
but this is where some
of the opportunity is
in terms of new revenue, right?
This could be, you know,
a sales agent as a service
or a market agent as a service.
As we move into this agentic space,
you know, you'll start
to see a lot of these
types of offerings from partners.
Now on the bottom left, embed,
this is for new features for
existing customer base, right?
So you're embedding AI features
and in this quadrant you're probably not
charging anything extra,
but this could be a really
good retention strategy
if you're in a competitive market
and you wanna make sure
you retain your customer
with more value embedding
and bringing those
agentic capabilities could
be one of the approaches
that you can take.
And then finally, in terms of expanding,
this is new products with
existing customer base, right?
So you can have some
complementary solutions
along with your existing products
where you're still targeting
your existing customer base,
but it can be a additional
revenue stream for you.
So just a quick framework
to kind of think about
how to bring agentic capabilities
within your solution.
So feel free to take a QR code of that
and then, you know, it
goes into much more detail
on the white paper that we have.
Now, once you figure out what
your agentic capabilities are,
like how do you go to market with AWS?
So earlier this year we
launched the AI agents
and tools marketplace in July,
and this is our one stop
shop for customers to find
all of our agentic
offerings from our partners.
And when partners come to AWS Marketplace,
they expect to see
agentic type of offerings.
And we've categorized our AI agents
and tools section within AWS Marketplace
so they can find them in
three different categories.
And those three different
categories are the first category
being just AI agents.
This is where you can
find some prebuilt agents
or agents that are embedded
into software applications
or even, you know, agent
development platforms
that allow you to build
your own agents, right?
So that's one work stream
of potential solutions
that customers will find.
And then customers are also looking
as they're building their agent workflows,
they're looking for tools.
We have a lot of partners already
listing their MCP servers
on AWS Marketplace.
So that's another route that's possible.
And then finally for consulting partners,
we have many consulting
partners that provide
AI strategy consulting as
well as implementing that.
So all of those offerings get bubbled up
to our customers when they
come to AWS Marketplace
and look in the AI agents
and tools marketplace.
Now there's a lot of benefits associated
with the AI agents and tools
that are in AWS Marketplace.
I'd like to have my
colleague Leno come up here
and talk a little bit about that.
- Perfect.
Thank you, Seenu.
So this is a partner session.
I want to get a quick poll.
Who here has a listing
in Marketplace today?
Perfect, so a good number of you.
Now, for those that ,
allow me to convince you.
AWS Marketplace is a
curated digital catalog
that makes it really
easy for AWS customers
to find your products, subscribe
and purchase your products,
and then deploy them in the
location that they need them.
Partners that lean into
AWS Marketplace benefit
from deal acceleration from
the procurement efficiency
that they get from AWS Marketplace.
Also, when you sell in AWS Marketplace,
you're aligning with the
broader AWS strategic goals,
so you get to grow with us.
And lastly, partners that
are in AWS Marketplace
get to leverage the vast AWS co-sell,
a network that has global reach.
And now AWS Marketplace
is also the best place
to list your agents and tools.
Let's understand why.
Flexibility is gonna be a theme
that I bring up a few times here.
Marketplace gives you the
flexibility to price your agents
and tools how your customers
want to purchase them.
So we offer usage-based pricing,
and this is great for, really
it's great for all customers,
everyone wants usage-based pricing,
but it's particularly important
for your smaller customers
or one-off developers
that want to kick the
tires on an agent or tool,
pay for what they consume
before they commit to a broader contract.
And the way this works in marketplace
is that your agent will track that usage
and report it to marketplace,
and then marketplace will
automatically bill the customer
and then disperse payment
directly into your bank account.
We also offer contracts pricing
and with contracts pricing,
this is an obvious favorite
for enterprise customers,
you're able to transact upfront payments
and you can have broad
durations in that contract.
And we make it really easy
to manage your licenses
with that contract by giving
you access to several tools.
So it's easy for you to check
entitlements on contracts
that you purchase, your
customers purchase rather.
And both pricing models are
supported by AWS Marketplace
private offers.
Private offer in marketplace
is an agreement between you
and a customer.
So you can negotiate
terms that are favorable
to both parties and then transact
that directly in AWS Marketplace.
And when you transact through
private offers in marketplace,
you can set up flexible payments
to make it really convenient
for you and your customers
to disperse payments on a schedule
that makes sense for both of you.
Continue on the flexibility.
So AWS Marketplace makes it
easy for you to sell your agents
and tools with a deployment method
that makes sense for your customers again.
So we offer API based agents.
Here you're hosting the
agent in your own AWS account
and you're giving access to
the customer via an endpoint,
and you can then integrate
into their own systems.
We also offer container-based
agents and tools.
Here you're defining your
agent as a Docker image
that is hosted in AWS Marketplace.
And then when the customer
purchases that product,
they're given access to that image
and they can deploy it in the container
orchestration service of their choice.
And then we also support
professional services
and additional software offerings as well.
So now you can offer your
design implementation services
to complement your agents and tools,
and you can always sell SaaS
that has agentic solutions
embedded in it as well,
the software offerings.
Now, hopefully this is enough
to pique your interest
in selling your agents
and tools in AWS Marketplace,
but the reason why I
think it's the best place
to sell your agents and tools
is because AWS Marketplace
is tightly integrated
with Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
Hopefully by now you've gotten a lot
of great information on
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
This is a quick refresher.
AgentCore is a platform that
allows you to easily develop,
maintain, and operate agents
and tools directly on AWS.
And we think it's how
customers are going to want
to develop the future of
their agentic systems.
And those same customers want access
to partner agents and tools
so that they can make their development
both easier and more productive.
And for the partners,
AgentCore offers a ton of flexibility.
We support multiple frameworks,
all the leading frameworks,
all the foundation models
available on Bedrock
and all the leading protocols
like A2A and MCP.
So your solutions might already
be AgentCore compatible.
When you list your API
listing in marketplace,
you make it that much easier
for customers to connect it
to their solutions with
just a few lines of code.
And the same goes for the
container-based offering.
Let's see how this works in practice.
So it starts with you listing
a product in AWS Marketplace.
In this run through,
I'm gonna show the flow
for both container-based
and API-based listings.
Then you have a buyer that
subscribes to your offerings.
For the container path,
once a buyer subscribes
through marketplace,
they're guided through a
closely controlled workflow
that eventually results in them
deploying an agent directly
in AgentCore runtime.
And AgentCore runtime
is the serverless hosting
environment for AgentCore.
For the API based deployment method.
That same customer is again
guided through marketplace
provided with an endpoint
and the necessary keys
to use that endpoint,
and they get access to your agent,
which is running in
your own seller account.
Now, the buyer will take these agents,
integrate them into their applications
to enhance their own applications
to make it agentic.
As they consume, each agent
is reporting that usage
to AWS Marketplace.
And then marketplace is billing the buyer
and then dispersing payment directly
into your seller account.
So that's the whole flow.
Now I'd like to show you
what this looks like from the
actual customer experience,
just to show visually how
easy it is for a customer
to subscribe to and use an
agent from AWS Marketplace.
So this is an example listing
of a container based
agent in AWS Marketplace.
And here you're seeing
all the various things
that you can show on your detail page.
You can have videos, everything.
With one click, you're sent
into a subscription experience.
Here a customer can view the
various usage costs associated
with this product, terms, conditions,
and they have a few configurations here.
With one click they can subscribe.
In a couple minutes the
system will go through
and they click a button
to launch that agent.
Now they select Bedrock
AgentCore as a deployment method.
They're given some instructions
for what they'll need to do
to make the most use out of that agent,
but they have a one click button there
to actually deploy that
agent directly in AgentCore.
And now you have an
endpoint that's ready to use
and integrate directly into
your agentic system solutions.
So that could be your product right there.
To close off I want to give
you access to some resources
that will help guide you
through your next steps.
If you're interested in listing
in marketplace in general,
you can find everything
over in our seller guide
and it'll point you all the resources
for all the various products
that you can have in marketplace.
Also, please do take
the time to explore more
and learn about Bedrock
AgentCore if you haven't already.
And lastly, I'll invite
you to learn more about
joining the AWS Generative AI Competency.
It's a new competency
for the partner network
and we think you're gonna
be really excited about it.
Thank you, everyone.